it is often said that California is
about five years ahead of the rest of
the country nationally well I give you
this story from the Hill California
first state to ban natural gas heaters
and furnaces quote while this strategy
will clean the air for all Californians
it will also lead to reduced emissions
in the many low-income and disadvantaged
communities that experience greater
levels of persistent air pollution ah
it's for the poor people that you can't
have heat anymore okay poor people don't
need heat yeah no right yeah I mean yeah
poverty generates energy right they're
just naturally warm you know plus I
think they probably already have tools
they can create fire this always this
kind of stuff always reminds me of um
I always forget to what play it is
anyway it's uh it's Chekhov and then
three sisters what's his name I have it
right now Anton Chekhov yeah and he's
saying uh he's saying ah it's Uncle
Vanya it's Uncle Vanya it's Uncle Vanya
and he's talking about the trees and why
do the peasants always burn down the
trees
you know and he's like why is this why
the peasants need to burn down the trees
can't they just use peat they can pick
it up off the ground and burn that and
of course burning peat is a much dirtier
um it's a much dirtier Source the smoke
is worse and all of that
um but we're constantly trying to tell
everybody how they need to
Heat their homes how they need to you
know move around all of this so that's
unreasonable they ban gas cars they're
banning natural gas heaters so
everything's going to be electric
everything's going to be electric it's
going to collapse it already is
collapsing and then already I mean you
saw this we talked about this and uh
then they tell you that you can't charge
your cars right so it's all it what what
the end result is is going to be
controlling your movements it controls
what it really is is artificial scarcity
this is done in order to control
populations as you're limiting energy
you limit also almost everything else in
someone's life in society you're also
able to limit their food their travel
and their progression and any kind of
upward economic Mobility has been robbed
and Stripped Away from the average
American as of course we're all told
that we're doing it for the right causes
we're doing it as the people literally
causing the most amount of pollution in
this world are are flying around in
their private jets and and swimming
around in their yachts and living in
their Mansions why aren't they
restricted if this was really truly
about helping the environment maybe the
over consumers maybe the richest people
in this world maybe the people who have
way too much would have been dealt with
in a truly communistic kind of system if
we're going by their rules and laws but
we're not doing any of that artificing
the poorest people and creating some of
the poorest people in this world and
what this is is exactly artificial
scarcity to predominantly bring in more
controls by governments that want to run
every aspect of your life but so the
Teslas have cell connectivity and it's
going to be funny in what five years
when you're going to be in your garage
and there's going to be a notice saying
not charging on your Tesla or electric
car you're gonna sit down and you're
gonna be like I only have 30 battery I
can't go anywhere and it's like
Governor's orders emergency green
lockdown your but your part your car's
not charging so then what people will do
is they're going to get Faraday cages
you're going to try and like airplane
mode you can't airplane mode the car the
car always have the connectivity so
people will be like oh build the Faraday
cage so the internet can't tell it what
to do you're going to go in your car and
it's going to be like no connectivity
can't charge it's going to connect to
the internet to charge your vehicle yeah
that's going to do that yeah and it's
just going to keep you where you are and
then they're going to tell you what food
that you can eat and everything yeah
we're talking about Central planning
you're going to get in your car it's
going to be charged and you're going to
punch in the address for your work
you're going to pull out get under the
road and then all of a sudden it's going
to turn the lights in the car will turn
red and then the car will just start
driving and it'll be like Warren warrant
submitted for Ian Crossland driving to
fifth Precinct and you're gonna go what
and it's like warrant for excessive
energy use orange juice you're just
going to say that you can go to work and
you can't go anywhere else
it'll drive you to the police completely
antithetical to the United States the
Constitution of freedom of property
freedom of speech freedom of accident
like I don't know that's why they're
trying to get rid of it
just doesn't makes I mean the god of the
government's got to understand that
essentially trying to essentially plan
people's lives is not good the Soviet
Union did that and collapsed but they
think they're doing it for altruistic
reasons they think they're doing it to
help us
no one accuses do you think that
overpopulation is actually a threat yes
I don't think I don't think it is the
science and data prove it's not like
overpopulation of deer for instance
aren't we below replacement rate right
now yes
the issue is the density of cities so
but that was okay but the density of
cities was already part of the
sustainable movement was to like get
more people into cities that's a
terrible idea because it creates it
generates massive waste that can't be
washed away but it also I mean there are
ways to there are these like living
machines have you guys heard about this
that like it's like they're not they're
not pods bugs no it's not bugs it's like
an entire Flora system that it's not a
composting toilet it's like the next
step from a composting toilet it's like
The Next Step Up
anyway it's a toilet it's not a toilet
it's a whole system it's a living
machine and it takes all of the waste
and it turns it into like a big Garden
kind of thing and you can put these in
apartment buildings that you turn into
cities so you have like massive
apartment building cities that have zero
um carbon footprint they produce no
waste because it's all goes through
these living machines anyway it does
this whole thing but so my point is if
massive growth of cities which to a
certain extent is part of a sustainable
idea
is a failure as well
why isn't it apparent that like we
haven't come up with the right idea yet
right so why are we continuously
enforcing these ideas that have not been
proven out
we need to live like they lived in
Avatar you know I didn't see that live
under trees and hold hands and rock back
and forth oh right but I think that
they're afraid of zoonotic disease or
the humans are disturbed because they
have in one way they're like cities are
grossly overpopulated but secondly
they're like we need people in mega
cities because we don't want them to
disrupt if that was like the 2050 City
remember that the like 2050 city was a
thing before the 2035 no car thing
they're continuously coming up with
these ideas so like they're afraid that
humans are going to poison the Earth so
instead they're going to try and force
them into large cities that are
poisonous to the Earth yes a lot of the
policies that you're seeing done in the
name of climate change are creating more
climate change especially when it comes
to you know limiting energy shooting uh
you know down nuclear reactors getting
rid of of you know energy that could be
explored that could be produced there's
there's been domestic policies in Europe
in the United States that deliberately
hinder energy to the people energy is
correlated to economic prosperity and
and this is to me done deliberately
people call it the great reset people
call it the great collapse I think there
are far larger consequences to this than
than the average person even kind of
understands or could even comprehend
here so so if you look at a lot of these
policies a lot of them are correlated
with more pollution more disastrous uh
you know situations for the poorest
people in the world
I was thinking of that wall the wall and
that where Saudi Arabia or UAE somewhere
they want to build this large city oh
the line the line yeah the line and
maybe nonsense they're thinking that
it's defensible if chaos were to erupt
on Earth and there was a global war that
the large cities mega cities we could
defend them with air support we know
where everyone is and chaos is dangerous
but like the realistic thing is if
everything's concentrated in one area
then it's a bombing Target it also seems
really disgusting and horrible like
you'd be trapped because it would be a
walled City like that's that's such
regression we used to have like Paris
was a walled City you know I don't think
we need a walled City yeah you can't go
outside you can't be free you can't
escape the prison that they're literally
building for you and in in many cities
there's already but only poor people
yeah exactly yeah because everybody else
has their own way Lauren and and Zach
and and they're gonna have their Jacobs
they're gonna have their Elysium in the
sky they're gonna have their private
island up in the sky it feels like this
technocratic obsession with order is
like a video game like they think it's
gonna work like a video game but people
are chaotic by Nature they are chaotic
and that's that's how we are that's how
humans and monkeys have always been we
rip and tear and grow and die and so I
don't understand what these what these
videos are are intending what the what
this technological generation think
these are these are also the people the
people they want there to be 500 million
people and so they are working towards
making less people these are also the
same people though that would have you
believe that Native Americans were
peaceful and didn't you know they would
like infantilize indigenous populations
and say that they had no none of the
kind of impulses that modern man has
you know that's crazy too
yeah we were talking about that a couple
days ago on the show uh I think I think
we had a interesting conversation about
that as well there's there's a lot of
things that we don't know especially
when it comes to history I think you
know if you think the news is fake wait
until you find out about history and uh
you know you you really examine who's
telling us these kind of narratives you
kind of have to ask yourself why are we
being told these specific things why is
this being reiterated to us and at the
end of the day I think it's a lot of it
is to weaken the human Spirit the human
will and I think largely you know trying
to understand it I I I think it's
difficult for many people because it's
impossible to get into the mind of
someone who might be a sociopath or
someone who truly is a part of maybe a
larger energetic demonic world out there
so there's all potentials out here it's
not worth speculating but it is worth
documenting the the the things that they
do and the effects that they have on
humanity and you cannot argue that
within the last three years all the
centralized policies have wrecked havoc
on the average average human being we
have destroyed our way of life we have
destroyed our physical health our mental
health our intelligence our our ability
to have family members to procreate and
live life here on this human Planet
we've destroyed all of that because we
have given authority to the government
and I think the more that the government
exists the more that they do the more
that the average human being lives in
Havoc the less government does the less
Havoc we have and I think this is why
you know one of the answers is
decentralization I mean I think in a lot
of cases everything that you're saying
about you know how we did that
um I think a lot of it was not people
giving the authority but having the
authority taken and us just looking at
it like oh my goodness they're they're
doing this they're taking this I think
that we were relatively complacent about
the luxury of our lifestyles about our
ability to move and exist freely say
what we think you know have seek the
medical treatment that we think is
appropriate all of this and I think that
a lot of us I know that I was
um despite everything sort of shocked to
see how the government just came in and
obliterated our rights and just
completely took them away started lying
to us about everything right I mean if
we've we've talked about this you know
like stay in your homes don't go to work
you're you're massively germy except if
you're protesting black Trans lives in
front of the Brooklyn Museum then it's
fine and it was just so shocking to be
lied to consistently and to be told that
those lives were truth and you're just
standing there with your mouth wide open
in shock to be told this after here you
thought you were in a democratic system
with
um good values where we all agreed on
the Bill of Rights and then just to have
it squashed I mean I don't think that we
necessarily gave the authority to do all
of this to the government I think it was
taken and we were stunned because we
didn't expect it and I think you can
look at that in a number of areas of
American life including education so I
talked to a lot of people who are
education activists particularly
conservatives and parents who realized
only during you know we only really
realized during the pandemic when school
came home and it turned out to be trash
what was being done to our kids you know
that this indoctrination was already in
there it had been in there for years it
wasn't new it was it the only reason
it's in the news now is because it has
been realized so people trusted all of
these systems we trusted our
institutions we trusted our you know
government to a large degree
only to find out that they were
deceiving us
successfully and then the people that
sat by and said nothing or did nothing
while it happened or I think Martin
Luther King would say was it that the
the evil will come from the men that see
evil and do nothing right or say nothing
I had some quote like that right A lot
of people just went along with it all
that is required for evil to try them is
that good men do nothing right yeah and
so and if you don't even see it if you
don't see it happening
you know if it has been so sick if that
evil has been so successfully obfuscated
then you're just stunned when you when
you realize that it's admin all around
you that makes sense yeah the term too
expert that that is a way to obfuscate
evil for sure because if you tell or
tell someone that an expert is claimed
or an expert's here now appeal to
Authority yeah I generally want to
listen to people that are experts at
what they do but it doesn't mean that
they're right right
and the siloing of information I think
was a problem you when you go to school
um it used to be when you go to school
you could become a generalist you know
the idea was that you would know a
little bit about everything and this was
a good thing and now they're still you
know they're like oh career classes in
middle school and it's like you don't
need that yeah the last thing you need
is a career class what you need is an
art class and a science class and like
and like what doctors need is a health
class as well like like a food a food
health class and a medicine Healthcare
I just want to add to your point here
because you talked about a little bit of
the censorship and I do believe if it
wasn't for the censorship the lockdowns
the mandates the Ridiculousness the
punishing of individuals would have not
lasted as long as it has but because of
this centralization of our information
and our thoughts through big Tech social
media algorithms I think it was the only
reason why they were able to get away
with so much atrocities with so much
bullcrap against the average human being
so so I just wanted to kind of uh talk
about that point that you made and and
point it out as one of the biggest
factors to why humanity went along with
this lunacy because they didn't know
that there was another alternative
another option or that the science was
even debated or talked about I think
that's exactly right they called it
misinformation they would ban you censor
you get you fired doctors literally get
you fired you know from your job
suddenly you can't feed your family we
see this all over the place
it's and I think it was shocking to a
certain extent
um
I mean it's good that we're aware of it
now the question it I mean the price we
paid is huge the real question that we
need to be asked that nobody wants to
ask is are the people running these
programs people or are they aliens
that's right my son was asking me that
the other day he's like Mom what if
we're the aliens and I was like that's
panspermia what if aliens what what if
we started the seti project we send out
was it Voyager with that golden desk is
that what had it I think yeah yeah the
record the record on it what if aliens
found it and they were like these people
are so dumb and then they came here and
they were like we're in control now what
if they found it and they were like
these people are so intelligent we just
can't possibly go to that quadrant yeah
yeah people are definitely afraid of the
unknown and if you can't see what the
virus then that's a way to scare people
like if you see the lion charging
through the city you at least know what
to fear and if the lion gets killed
everyone knows the Danger's over but if
you can't see it I mean if aliens want
to get us they'll be like LOL let's give
them an invisible threat it just feels
like everything we saw over the lockdown
pounds was like a test can't will people
like will will you pull up into a
parking lot and inject a foreign
substance into your arm from a stranger
now like I understand that you trust the
people on the TV box when he says go to
your local 7-Eleven parking lot but I
kept telling people like please don't do
that please go to a doctor because like
we don't want to normalize a culture of
like walking up to a random person and
being like yes inject me with that I
want to go to a doctor ask the doctor
let them figure out and not in doctors
aren't always right or whatever but the
point is like you're safest there as
opposed to the guy at the 7-Eleven this
is not a dead show don't just take what
the man offers you isn't that crazy
though I feel like you know taking crazy
pills Ian's confused well I'm thinking
like wait isn't it if you go to a duty
he's drugging you maybe they don't use
that phrase because the guy might be
considered a doctor and it's supposed to
be a healthy thing he's putting your arm
but it's still he's still drugging you
with a drug that could be good for you
you don't know look you get a
prescription from a doctor you go to the
doctor like this are some people your
doctor say like here's my history here's
my risk factors and let them tell you
what's right or not you don't want to
like imagine I'll tell you this let's
say I love using the plumbing analogy
let's say your toilet bursts like just
just crap everywhere and it's a mess and
there's water spreading all over the
place and then bits are floating on the
floor
this is good so imagine you decide I
gotta get this fixed so you pull into a
7-Eleven parking lot where there's a
random guy you say hey come fix my
toilet is that that makes no sense no
you call a plumber but you might be
before you might have a plunger so he
must have been good at what he did
because he had a plunger because he had
a plunger that's why it's just we we
normalize this and it's just absolutely
insane to me that they were people but
I'll I'll slow down it feels like
at the very least we collected some
great data yeah people are willing to
drive up to a random parking lot in a
place they've not been and let a strange
person inject them with a foreign
to get a vaccine by your job you could
call your doctor right and say Here's my
age here's my risk factors tell me what
to do doc that I think is acceptable but
in any circumstance walk into a parking
lot and being like howdy stranger right
here that's nuts the last 20 years has
been like the The Awakening of the
American people this great red pilling
where we're seeing some people haven't
woken up yet or maybe never will but a
lot of people covet had to happen to
them they had to be smacked down by
authoritarian nightmare to realize what
an authoritarian nightmare is some
people saw the data in 2007 and were
like whoa there weren't weapons of mass
destruction in Iraq holy crap why are we
still in Afghanistan in 2011 what's this
trans-pacific partnership what's this
investor State dispute settlement that
wants to sell us out to Malaysian oil
companies this what's this
corporatization of the world and there
they woke up and they're alive they're
talking about it but a lot of people are
still in that process and a lot of those
people got the jab without questioning
it I just want to point out that once we
reach two thousand dollars in super
chats Luke is going to down this whole
tube hell no
no no all right Libby will down this
whole nobody wants to
I think we have like a quart of icing
right here with these two things but you
have to make those gingerbread castles
with them yeah somebody sent us these
gingerbread boxes like two years ago and
they're expired and I cracked them open
and those icings were in it and I was
like all right who's gonna slam one of
these on the show no we have to make the
gingerbread houses that's what you have
to do yeah use it as glue or something
do you eat gingerbread house like you're
supposed to actually eat them no you're
desperate you can yeah if you're
desperate like yeah think about that as
an American like I used excess food to
make a structure that I'm not going to
eat it's just for decoration it's a food
structure that's so weird I don't like
food structure thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there